opposition politicians lead protests
against president kaya syed in the
capital tunis they accused saeed of
corrupting democratic institutions and
wanting absolute power and control over
tunisia
these years known as the black decade
are the years during which tunisia wrote
its greatest constitution and
established institutions including the
supreme judiciary council and the
independent national authority for
elections the institutions built by the
revolution and built by the martyrs are
today threatened by kai syed and his
group
saeed suspended parliament and assumed
executive powers last year and dissolved
it in march
he's also sacked dozens of judges he
wants a referendum next month to change
tunisia's constitution a draft version
is due to be published on monday
god willing on the 20th of the month i
will according to the law submit the
draft constitution to the president this
being the maximum date for the
submitting of this draft
syed has banned polls and political
advertising and told international
election observers they're not welcome
turnout in the referendum is expected to
be low
these protesters say they won't give up
they don't believe the vote in july will
be free or fair they say saeed has too
much power and democracy is in danger
victoria gatenby al jazeera